give us an update on the tokenization so
your original proposal came out
obviously the NBA wasn't so hot on it
you kind of reworked a little bit where
are you with that right now and kind of
what updates do you have for people yeah
so I mean obviously I always have to
preface these things by saying you gotta
contact the broker-dealer on file I
choked on capital you know we're doing
everything obviously on the up-and-up it
is for red creditor accredited investors
only but pretty much you know we started
the process back well sure when we start
the process and went through all the
legalese and everything it was shoot 18
maybe 20 months ago now but when we kind
of started talking to the NBA was in
September of last year obviously like
you said they were too hot on it
we continued to go forward talk to them
kind of settle on a structure that was
more like a pilot it's a bond obviously
and then you know attaching a safe to it
for the larger business investment as
well but you know that like I said
multiple times I view this as the start
of an asset class it's about unlocking
liquidity and and creating fan
engagement so my bond is not necessarily
the most interesting thing in the world
but as this continues to scale there's
gonna be a host of different things you
know any business can offer any product
they want and you know we all
individually are our own businesses yeah
and I think what's really interesting
about this right if you came out with
some that was really really innovative
and then you kind of get walked back a
little bit to something that you know
your words is more boring but it still
gets it done right and it's almost like
it's more important to get it done but
it is to have the most innovative
sexiest structure right out of the gate
is that fair oh that's not fair see and
that's why I try to you know communicate
to people a lot when you know they they
see things like to go formulæ show you
things like the initial kind of
spitballing of the offering and what was
reported or miss reported and some
places you know they think if you don't
do the absolute sexiest thing that you
somehow fail but in a lot of ways you
don't necessarily think that you're
going to get all that accomplished
when you're doing dealing with legacy
systems you understand they're gonna
draw their hard line somewhere but what
you're saying is this is all of what I
want to do now tell me what you're going
to allow me to do and where we can work
together and so there's typically a mid
line that you know you get to because
you were bold enough to say what it is
that you want it to do but if you come
out and you and you tiptoe they
typically would just try to hush you and
move you over to the side and say you're
not gonna do it and then you knows
people pack their bags and go home you
have to have enough gumption to you know
really kind of try it yeah do you think
that there would have been a different
approach from the league's perspective
if it wasn't so much drawn to the the
player contract and had been more like
sponsorships or something like that
or is it just generally the idea of
tokenizing a revenue stream from a
player and having fans potentially
invest in it that's really what it was
kind of they were trying to wrap their
head around quite obviously I think it's
uh both you know I think they don't
necessarily want the the athlete taking
control of their revenue streams or
their fan engagement or really blurring
that line between themselves and the
fans and really making it a cohesive
unit in a sense I think because their
jurisdiction does deal with clear
contracts that's why they were allowed
to say something if I was doing that
with you know Nike money for example
they could hate it all they want to but
if they came out against it I could very
easily just say hey like this has
absolutely nothing to do with you you
know so but that's where they had some
jurisdiction but at the same time I
don't think they would have liked it
regardless yeah and then you came out
with this go fund me which when I saw it
I literally said this dudes either the
biggest genius in the world or this is
going nowhere and so it's kind of what
was the the impetus for even starting it
and then kind how did you structure it
ya know so sort of go for me think it's
another kind of tool affair engagement
right like there's all these factors
that play into a person making a free
agency decision and simply we can they
try to keep it you know off to the side
right we talk about market size fan base
we talk about state taxes
the shoe company's gonna push you to a
team that has a lot of history or a team
that you know has a big media following
or whatever it is or your hometown etc
you know there's all these different
factors your family your friends all
that right well what if you involve the
fans in some of those decision-making
processes right like the CBA pretty much
states that you can't like take a
discount or anything like that so you
know when I tweeted and went back in
read the CBA I was like okay I have to
take out the minimum portion of it but
there's nothing in there that says they
can't be factors in your decisions quite
frankly if I'm choosing a team based
upon you know their their film based and
you know how big of a global presence
they are then I'm choosing it because of
those fans you know I just didn't tell
the fans that there why I'm choosing
them you know and so kind of reimagining
that know when I set the actual price
once again I said it sky high because
there was no way that it was gonna get
there and the way I chose that I
actually just picked my three favorite
numbers put them together multiplied it
by the price of Bitcoin and got it
people people thought I was choosing
like market value or something else I
literally took and I wrote it I took
twenty six twenty five point eight and
then multiply that by the price of
Bitcoin which is probably I think like
ninety two hundred at the time or
something in that range and that's how
we got the sky-high number and the
reason why I said you know if even if
we're a dime short it all goes to
charity and because of it about it was
about the idea and the concept how can
we enhance for an engagement how can we
bring more people in how can this
ecosystem thrive in the middle of kovat
if there are no fans in the in the
stands next year but guys want to do
some things that kind of keep people and
trenched in the game well what happens
if they literally chose a players
destination you know or of a player had
you know a set of three destinations he
said you know what I'm torn between you
know Brooklyn and two other teams you
guys pick you know and and and obviously
they wouldn't be able to talk about
money and things like that cuz that's
between the player and the team
negotiating but if that
if that was right for him and he could
do that and if we go fund me campaign or
another black shame-based you know
system allowed them to have that kind of
voting power in there then I mean
there's nothing saying that they
couldn't do that so you know like I said
it's picked sky-high numbers I knew I
wouldn't reach you it would end up in a
charity donation which you know I wanted
to do good during Cobra as well but it
was all about the concept and me idea
yeah my brother texted me I didn't see
it at first when you posted it and he
texted me he goes what's he doing and I
as soon as I read it I said he might be
a billionaire by the end of this if
people give him twenty five twenty five
million dollars a Bitcoin whoa like what
did happen I would have definitely been
a shock to say the least but yeah I mean
the plan was definitely always to give
the money charity that's why you know I
wrote it in there like that